bonjour merci de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil 78 nouvelle édition du 78 lactu
voici les titres de ce vendredi la TVA
pour les cinémas vient de passer de 7 à
5,5 % conséquence les enfants âgé de
moins de 14 ans bénéficie d'un tarif
avantageux à 4 € la mesure vient de la
fédération nationale des cinémas
français le centre de ressources
ivelinois pour la musique le cri qui
interpelle les candidats au municipal
son directeur nous expliquera pourquoi
il s'associe à cette opération vut-on
plus de musique dans nos Yvelines qui
vise à soutenir les équipements et les
démarches de proximité musique également
avec ce spectacle ce mardi 14 janvier à
la ferme de BBA une composition
électroacoustique sur des textes de Jean
joress une nouvelle création musicale
actuellement en
répétition l'image du jour c'est au
lycée orticool de mole près d'
berganville une soixantaine d'élèves de
l'établissement Lebua ont été touchés
par une infection intestinale collective
en cause selon les premiers éléments de
l'enquête à un plat de spaghetti servi à
la cantine aux élèves internes les
jeunes entre 13 et 20 ans ont été
conduits dans les hôpitaux voisins pour
de nouveaux examens la TVA a augmenté
vous le savez vous l'avez constaté dans
la plupart des cas mais pas pour les
cinémas elle diminue même de 7 à 5,5 %
mais n'attendez pas une répercussion
directe sur vos tickets d'entrée seul
les moins de 14
vont sentir la différence pour leur
porte-monnaie Anthony r nous apporte
plus de
précision les familles sont les grands
gagnants de la baisse de la TVA
désormais lorsque vous emmènerez vos
enfants au cinéma leur place vous
coûtera 4 € un nouveau prix dû à la
diminution de la taxe pour le grand
écran de 7 à 5,5 %. mais cette offre
mettrait en difficulté les petites
salles qui se démarquaient jusqu'à
présent par des tarifs attractif et qui
dénonce un gros manque à gagner on peut
pratiquer des tarifs plus bas donc
permettre sera plus de monde de venir
dans les salles mais nous ça va encore
nous baisser encore un petit peu bon un
tout petit peu plus cher mais ça va
encore nous baisser un tout petit peu ça
va jouer sur notre chiffre d'affaires
quoi et comme on sait qu'on a des
chiffres d'affaires qui sont un peu
ricraac c'est un peu difficile ça va
surtout profiter au grand circuit grâce
à des convention signées avec les villes
d'élancour et morpa les jeunes habitants
de ces communes payent déjà leur place
au ciné entre 2,50 € et 3 €. cette offre
à 4 € est aussi une manière d'inciter
les Français à revenir dans les salles
dont la fréquentation ne devrait pas
dépassé les 200 millions d'entrées en
2013 soit 10 % de moins qu'en 2011
malgré les faits d'annonce cette baisse
de la TVA é en réalité un simple retour
à la taxation de 2012 la tranche des 6
14 ans représente à l'heure actuelle
près de 10 % des clients des salles
obscures cette opération de réduction de
la TVA devrait coûter près de 20
millions d'euros à l'industrie du cinéma
français du cinéma à la musique mais
aussi à la politique le Rif la
Confédération des réseaux départementaux
des musiques actuelles et ampli en
Île-de-France lance cette opération
votons plus de musique dans nos villes
pour 2014 le centre de ressources
evvelinois pour la musique véhicule sur
le terrain cette initiative bonjour
Thierry Duval vous êtes le directeur
donc du cri et le constat c'est
qu'aujourd'hui malgré l'engouement du
public pour la musique il n'est pas
possible d'en profiter pleinement on
manque de salle on manque de structure
voilà c'est qu'en fait il y a un
décalage entre l'image qu'on a de la
musique qui est très présent dans notre
société à travers notamment des grands
rassemblements des grands festivals des
salles qui des grandes salles qui se
remplissent avec des artistes
internationaux
mais pour le l'habitant le méloman au
quotidien aller voir des concerts de
proximité pour le musicien trouver les
endroits pour répéter avoir des offres
d'apprentissage adapté à la musique qu'
a envie de jouer ça reste très difficile
vous vous parlez pardon dans certains
endroits de déserts musicaux
véritablement bah quand on regarde sur
le la carte des ibines par exemple c'est
vrai qu' a des endroits où c'est très
difficile d'avoir des endroits pour
répéter d'aller voir des concerts des
artistes qu'on apprécie dans des champs
musicaux comme le rayer le métal voilà
des formes de rock de chansons qui sont
pas les plus populair forcément ça
s'explique comment c'est un manque
d'initiative de la part des politiques
par exemple alors il y a peut-être une
une incompréhension générale peut-être
sur le ce que sont les réité de la
musique dans notre société aujourd'hui
la manière dont les gens s'approprient
différentes formes musicales les besoins
qu'ils ont justement en terme d'endroit
adaptés pour les pratiquer et ce qui est
véhiculé par les grands médias donc on
peut comprendre que des élus des
responsables ne sentent pas spontanément
l'intérêt de développer des lieux pour
les musiciens c'est tout le rôle du cri
d'avoir ce cette dimension pédagogique
donc d'inviter les élus à réfléchir et à
visiter notamment c'est ce qu'on met en
place des endroits qui fonctionnent bien
qui répondent à ses attentes il en a un
certain nombre dans les Ilin
heureusement pour faire en sorte qu'un
peu partout les gens aent des réponses
de proximité parce que la question de
proximité est très importante on
pourrait faire le parallèle avec le
sport où on comprend très bien que dans
les villes il y a besoin d'avoir des
équipements sportifs pour que les gens
pratiquent des sports en toute
simplicité c'est pareil dans la musique
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont une
pratique amateur il y a un engouement
formidable sur le fait de jouer dans
l'instrument de jouer en groupe de se
produire et les réponses ne sont pas
toujours présentes quels sont les
mauvaises élèves quels sont les villes
où il est difficile déjà de pratiquer la
musique difficile alors c'est plutôt la
question d'avoir une réponse au niveau
de la municipalité qui soit
satisfaisante alors c'est vrai qu'on
cite souvent les deux plus grandes
communes des ivelines que sont
Versailles et Sartrouville où
effectivement c'est pas là où il y a le
plus de réponses adaptées oou peut-être
il y a une posture qui est plus sur une
logique d'OF où on se dit il faut
proposer à la population d'aller voir
des concerts d'artistes internationaux
ou nationaux et pas forcément d'avoir
une attention particulière et soutenue à
la hauteur en tout cas par rapport à
tous les habitants de cette ville qui
ont des pratiques musicales très
diverses très varié et qui appelle à des
savoir-faire des équipements très
spécifiques en revanche il y a des
villes où ça se passe plutôt bien voilà
il y a des villes bah après j'invite à
aller consulter le site du crie ou
l'ensemble des structures qui composent
notre réseau donc 20 structures sur le
département des ivelines essaye de
justement de d'apporter des solution
voilà on a paré de rambbouiller
Saint-Germain manth her là il existe
aussi bien des structures pour écouter
les groupes découvrir des des nouveautés
musicales et puis et puis également à
des endroits où pratiquer cette musique
justement développer la musique ça passe
par quoi aujourd'hui par des des salles
pour les que les les groupes viennent se
produire ça passe par la promotion le
soutien peut-être même financier pour
les jeunes groupes ça passe par quoi
alors ça passe par effectivement déjà
prendre conscience de ce que ça veut
dire l'engagement dans la musique c'est
pas qu'une question culturelle ou
artistique c'est aussi un enjeu social
puisque il y a beaucoup de gens qui
trouvent leur épanouissement leur raison
d'être même dans la pratique musicale
c'est un enjeu aussi d'insertion
professionnelle puisqueil y a beaucoup
d'artistes on en a des exemples dans les
eveling qui ont trouvé leur voix
professionnelle en étant accompagné dans
leur pratique pris en compte accè AC et
donc c'est un enjeu qui est qui est très
large et qui mérite effectivement des
temps de discussion avec les
responsables culturels les élus pour
qu'ils puissent ensuite sur leur commune
et à la taille de la commune on n'est
pas pour des la mise en place de salles
partout dans toutes les communes c'est
pas du tout l'idée mais qu'on essaie
d'avoir une logique d'aménagement du
territoire satisfaisante et un peu plus
développée qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça qu'à travers toute l'île
de France et lancé cette opération
votons plus de musique et notamment
aussi forcément dans sur le terrain
yvelinois ça va se passer comment cette
opération votre plus de musique
c'està la diffusion à large échelle
d'une une plaquette qui explique un peu
cette démarche on va nous l'envoyer
communiquer voilà très important un site
internet fédérateur qui s'appelle
plusdemusique.fr sur lequel vous
trouverez des arguments des éléments
pédagogique on a aussi holdelaf un
artiste reconnu qui a participé à la
création de pastill vidéo qui explicite
un petit peu ses besoins des musiciens
on va organiser début février des temps
de communication important au niveau
régional sur pour mobiliser un peu les
gens expliquer en quoi effectivement
tout cette mouvement est important et
notre charge notre travail à nous dans
le mois qui vient va être aller à la
rencontre des candidats déclarés dans
les villes des ivelines en tout cas au
municipal pour voir de quelle manière
dans leur programme dans leurs
intentions ils peuvent aborder ses
question de la place de la musique dans
leur ville et pour l'instant les retours
que vous avez eu est-ce que les
candidats prennent en considration ou on
est plutôt on a commencé par un travail
au sein de notre réseau au niveau du
public des musiciens on voit bien que ça
rencontre un un comment dirais-je une
attention particulière on va dire que la
sauce commence à prendre ça prend de
l'ampleur et grâce à des médias comme
vous qui relayent l'information on
espère aussi que ça aille un peu plus
loin nous on est très confiant ça fait
c'est pas un travail qui est nouveau
pour nous ça fait des années qu'on mène
ce travail là mais il nous semble qu'on
atteint une une situation où il y a
vraiment des des choses à faire on a
vraiment par rapport à tout l'engouement
qu' a autour de la musique la manière
dont les politiques publiques
aujourd'hui se positionnent sur le champ
de la culture l'éducation artistique des
enjeux qui sont annoncés comme majeurs
il y a vraiment quelque chose à faire
autour de la musique tel que la pratique
les gens aujourd'hui vous avez mentionné
tout à l'heure l'artiste evelinois h de
LAF qui s'est engagé dans le cadre de de
cette campagne votons plus de musique en
2014 on va regarder justement l'une des
pastilles à laquelle a collaboré
l'artiste
petite pastille signé notamment h de la
votons plus de musique en 2014 vous
appelez aussi les les citoyens à
s'engager dans cette campagne et
interpeller les candidats leur mère
sortant par exemple exactement donc
l'idée c'est que tout cette démarche
avec l'argumentaire qui est présent sur
ce site sur les plaquettes puisse être
repris par les citoyens par les
associations locales qui se retrouvent
dans ce combat en quelque sorte pour all
interpeller leurs Éli au niveau local
nous on arriverait en quelque sorte en
soutien sur le site internet il y a la
possibilité de voter concrètement en
cliquant et en s'inscrivant sur sur ce
site pour cumuler agréger comme ça
comptabiliser en tout cas tous les gens
qui sont intéressés par cette campagne
donc j'invite les gens très largement
les mélomans les musiciens bien sûr
aller sur ce site et à se faire
connaître tout à l'heure vous l'avez dit
j'aimerais que l'on conclue aussi avec
ça la musique c'est un élément social
important surtout en cette période
peut-être un peu difficile vous le
ressentez aussi sur le terrain c'est
depuis le début ça l'a toujours été
c'estàd qu'en fait ça construit la vie
des gens ceux qui s'engagent dans un
parcours musical notamment qui jouent
d'instrument qui monent des groupes ça
structure un peu leur identité leur
parcours de vie plein de musiciens
peuvent en témoigner notamment tous ces
musiciens qui sont de ce qu'on appelle
les musiqu amateurs c'estàd des gens qui
ont pas forcément des visés
professionnelles mais pour qui ça
structure leur vie et c'est un élément
qui a prendre en compte fortement au
même titre que encore une fois on a pu
le prendre dans dans le domaine sportif
où on a compris que à travers une
activité sportive on pouvait accompagner
des des gens à s'épanouir à mieux se
trouver socialement la musique c'est la
même chose simplement faut être à
l'écoute faut comprendre un petit peu la
complexité de tous les engagements qu'il
y a dans la musique aujourd'hui qui sont
très diverses le jazz le rap la chanson
le rock c'est des choses aussi un peu
différente donc ça invite à comprendre
un petit peu ce qui se passe sur sa cité
sur sa sur sa ville et à la aller à la
rencontre des acteurs locaux le cri
existe depuis combi alors la démarche de
réseau c'est
1989 voilà ça fait 25 ans on les a
célébré au mois de décembre l'année der
et c'est la première fois que une telle
opération est menée oui c'est la
première fois et cette fois c'est au
niveau régional hein c'est 200
structures au niveau régional qui se
mobilisent autour de cette action c'est
la première fois qu'on le fait de
manière aussi structurée organisée et
peut-être avec des moyens un peu comme
ça que importants on va dire euh ceci
dit l'action du CRI a toujours été cette
action pédagogique hein on reçoit
régulièrement des élus de communes qui
veulent en savoir plus sur ces réalités
musicales qui veulent voir des
équipements des lieux qui fonctionnent
des stux de répétition des petites
salles de concert pour comprendre un
petit peu comment ça peut fonctionner
combien ça coûte à qu ça sert quel
public ça touche donc c'est un travail
pédagogique au quotidien qu'on mène là
on veut vraiment marquer le coup aller
au devant de tous les gens qui sont
concernés pour faire comprendre que il y
a vraiment quelque chose à jouer en
terme de politique locale autour de la
musique aujourd'hui la musique un enjeu
du prochain scrutin des municipales
merci thieré Duval d'être venu sur ce
plateau directeur du cri le site
internet
plusdemusique.fr au niveau de la région
Île-deFrance votons plus de musique
c'est to de la qui nous le dit pour
conclure
culture toujours mardi prochain 14
janvier la ferme de bbas AG guuill en
cour qui présente une composition
électroacoustique sur des textes de Jean
jores création musicale suivie par
Aurélia Deb en
avant-première quel que soit le métier
de la préciser de
l'profondir de l'établir et de la
coordonn cependant à la vie générale le
courage selon
Jean ces paroles extrait du discours à
la jeunèse prononcé en 1903 qui ouvre le
spectacle une création sonore à
l'univers électro acoustique dans lequel
viennent s'insérer des textes de Jean
jorè issus essentiellement de discours
et d'extraits de son mémoire
philosophique c'est la lecture de la
réédition de ce mémoire qui interpelle
Thierry Ballas il y a quelque chose moi
qui me touche dans la démarche de cet
homme dans sa démarche
intellectuel et que j'ai découvert en
lisant son mémoire de philosophie l'idée
que cet homme a eu engagement dans le
concret c'est quelqu'un qui s'est
beaucoup engagé au côté des ouvriers des
paysans et que tout cet engagement il
vient en fait d'un rapport au monde d'un
rapport à la nature et je trouve ça
assez intéressant c'est de ne pas subir
la loi du mensonge triomphant qui passe
et de ne pas faire écho de notre âme ce
spectacle propose des moments qui sont
assez popres des moments qui font qui
font référence à de la musique ancienne
on va vers les Folies d'Espagne vers
debusy il y a une petite citation de
debusy mais malgré tout on est aussi on
a aussi des moments qui sont plutôt dans
dans la musique expérimentale alors une
musique qui reste très écoutable mais
qui reste dans la recherche et et Jean
jores dit quelque chose moi qui m'a
beaucoup touché il dit par exemple un
son nouveau c'est la révélation d'une
force nouvelle d'une parcelle d'âme
inconnu et je trouve ça intéressant
cette idée que on peut avoir plusieurs
rapports à la musique il y a cette
musique qui répond à des codes sur
lesquel on est tous d'accord des
rapports harmoniques rythmiques sur
lesquels on est tous d'accord qui sont
un peu notre culture commune et ça c'est
super agréable à écouter parce que parce
que c'est évident il y a une espèce
d'évidence dans l'écoute et puis dis
Jean jores il y a une autre musique plus
expérimentale qui est peut-être un tout
petit peu plus compliqué à écouter mais
qui peut-être nous met en relation avec
des parties de notre âme que nous ne
connaissons pas encore voilà je trouve
que c'est un bel hommage à l'art
contemporain en général un voyage
musical intemporel autour d'une
réflexion sur le mouvement la lumière et
le
son la commanderie des templiersr en
cours on reste dans la culture a ouvert
ses portes au public en ce début d'année
l'occasion de découvrir la face cachée
de ce haut lieu du patrimoine
saintcantinois yoline tores Patrick
Jacques de dixmud pour les images les
Templiers c'est un ordre religieux et
militaire qui a été fondé en
118 retour à l'époque des croisades du
Moyen-Âge nous sommes à la Commanderie
des Templiers de la ville Dieu à hencour
à l'époque au 12e siècle les religieux
basés à Jérusalem se rendent compte que
les routes sont pavé de danger pour les
pélerins
c'est à partir de là que sonen est les
Templiers ce sont eux qui vont défendre
les routes menant jusqu'à la ville
sainte et c'est ici dans les
commanderies qu'ils se forent à l'art de
la guerre les Templiers sont des
chevaliers et on les envoyait pas
combattre en Orient tant qu'ils
n'étaient pas formés et ici vous pouviez
être formé à l'art de la guerre
notamment l'art équestre guerre de 100
ans guerre des religions le site connaît
les alléas de l'histoire de France les
destructions sont importantes mais les
bâtiments restent en demeure au 13e
siècle la France comptait près de de
1000 commanderies il n'en reste que très
peu aujourd'hui et ont souvent une
caractéristique commune la chapelle est
souvent voire exclusivement plus petite
que les autres bâtiments pour rappeler
que les Templiers n'ont pas une vocation
uniquement religieuse mais uniquement
une vocation militaire et agricole
puisque les commanderies fournissaient
l'ensemble des ressources pour les
Templiers qui partaient combattre en
Orient aujourd'hui le lieu est ouvert au
public et accueille aussi des
expositions d'art contemporain Patrice
est voisin depuis des années pour pour
la première fois il a visité la chapelle
la
restauration le sol aussi c'est nickel
et j'ai jamais eu l'occasion ou d'aller
soit à une conférence soit à des de la
musique dans la chapelle donc ça me
donne envie la prochaine fois quand il
auras quelque chose bah devenenir bien
sûr la prochaine fois ce sera le 2
février une visite organisée par le
musée de la
ville pour la suite de ce journal et
comme chaque vendredi nous revenons à
présent sur les fait marquant de
l'actualité de la semaine et on commence
par le verdict pour cette femme auicab
poursuivi par pour outrage lors d'un
contrôle de police mouvementé attrape en
juillet dernier elle a été condamnée
mercredi à 1 mois de prison avec surci
150 € à d'amende également on retiendra
que le tribunal a jugé irrecevable la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité posée sur
l'interdiction du voile intégral Anthony
resch et Jonathan villman étaient sur
place malgré son absence au tribunal
correctionnel de Versailles Cassandra
Belin jeune femme voilet de trappe a été
condamné à un mois de prison avec surcis
et à 150 € d'amende pour avoir refusé un
contrôle d'identité en juillet dernier
c'est plus qu'un rappel à la loi c'est
un rappel au aux principes fondamentaux
qui qui qui fondent la façon dont les
citoyens doivent vivre ensemble dans ce
pays c'est-à-dire dans le cadre de la
liberté de conscience évidemment mais en
respectant avant tout les règles
citoyennes qui fondent les valeurs
communes de la République française et
les dérogations qui sont demandées à ces
règles au nom de prétendus principes
igieux et bien doivent être fermement
dans le respect des textes naturellement
mais fermement rejetés et c'est ce qui
s'est passé ce matin quand on agresse un
policier le soir on doit dormir à la
prison voilà c'est une image pour nous
qui est extrêmement importante ce n'est
pas de la surenchère c'est simplement
que la police nationale ou la gendarmie
nationale sont considérés comme les
derniers remparts de la République et à
ce titre ils sont intouchables une
absence d'ailleurs déplorée par la
présidente du tribunal qui a regretté
qu'un débat ne se soit pas engagé et qui
voulait proposer à la cinquentinoise un
stage de citoyen
le tribunal a également jugé irrecevable
la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité sur l'interdiction du
voile soulevé par l'avocat de la jeune
femme de 20 ans convertie à l'islam dans
l'absolu c'est pas une décision sévère
mais vous savez que je faisais de cette
affaire une affaire de principe
notamment concernant la loi de 2011 sur
l'interdiction du por du voile donc ça
mérite réflexion et ça mérite de savoir
si nous allons poursuivre le combat
judiciaire ou pas le mari de Cassandra
Belin qui avait étranglé un policier le
jour des faits a lui écopé de 3 mois de
prison avec surc en novembre dernier en
juillet 2013 ce contrôle avait entraîné
de violents affrontement entre forces de
l'ordre et jeunes dans la ville
cinquantinoise lundi le gouvernement a
débuté l'année par un déplacement à
Versailles déplacement pour réaffirmer
sa politique en matière de droits des
femmes et de mixité retour sur cette
visite avec Claire
Cambier c'est à Versailles que le
premier ministre a choisi de faire sa
première visite officielle de l'année
plus préc prisment sur un chantier de
restauration du château lundi il y a
rencontré ces femmes qui ont choisi de
faire carrière dans le BTP un secteur
plutôt masculin Corine et chef d'équipe
traceur elle dirige C hommes un bel
exemple de mixité que cherche à
valoriser le gouvernement toutes les
expériences que j'ai pu faire de visite
de terrain montrre dans les centres de
formation dans les entreprises que
lorsqu'il y a un déclic lorsqu'on
favorise qu'on fait découvrir les
métiers alors les femmes il trouvent
leur place et l'entreprise y trouve
aussi son compte et c'est la société
toute entière qui progresse l'égalité
hommes-femm une des priorités affichées
du gouvernement après la parité
politique en 2013 place à la parité
professionnelle le Premier ministre a
annoncé des objectif ambitieux le
premier atteindre d'ici 2025 un taux
d'emploi identique pour les hommes et
les femmes il reste aujourd'hui plus de
9 points d'écart et pour cela il compte
faciliter l'accès au travail pour les
maires
et bien nous nous développons les modes
de garde nous faisons en sorte que par
exemple les femmes qui prennent un congé
parental soit accompagné au retour du
congé parental pour éviter qu'elles soi
placardisé à leur retour nous faisons en
sorte que les femmes après une longue
interruption à s'occuper de leurs
enfants puissent être accompagnés dans
la reconversion professionnelle nous les
soutenons pour développer une
entreprise deuxème objectif obtenir de
la mixité dans un tiers des métiers 10
secteurs clés sont visés de la petite
enfance à les sécurité civile Corine y
contribue déjà selon elle il faut savoir
faire bouger les choses je suis
constamment sur le chantier alors il
faut falloir s'imposer et avoir un
caractère quoi sinon les hommes ils V
marche le après l'entreprise qui
l'emploie fait figure de bon élève elle
a obtenu dès 2006 le label Égalité mais
le secteur du bâtiment est encore à la
traaine seul 1,6 % des ouvriers sont des
femmes décembre il évoquait la
possibilité d'une fermeture de son
établissement en raison de difficultés
financières un mois plus tard le
président de l'université de Versailles
50 ans nielin se veut rassurant il dit
avoir été mal compris et annonce surtout
avoir reçu un engagement financier de la
part de la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur Jean-Luc vessère était
l'invité du 78 lactus cette semaine ce
mardi je vous propose de réécouter
quelques-unes de ces
déclarations donc le ministère sera à
nos côtés pour nous aider à passer
l'année et à remplir
donc nos engagements évidemment payer
les salaires des fonctionnaires des
contractuels ça c'est un objectif très
important pour moi pour être bien cl
2014 le budget sera en déficite vous
finirez l'année en déficite avec ou non
d'ailleurs le soutien de l'État ça ça ne
changera pas mais il va falloir le
réduire quelle est la période fixée par
le le gouvernement au bout d'un moment
le gouvernement va vous dire on ne vous
êt plus débrouillez-vous voilà donc nous
ce qu'on a présenté qui a été validé par
le gouvernement par le ministère c'est
un plan sur 3 ans comme je commencé à le
dire tout à l'heure donc c'està dire que
2014 15 16 donc 2016 c'est l'équilibre
budgétaire voilà donc en mars on a déjà
pris des mesures parle au conseil
d'administration évidemment euh de
cadrage des formation Master ça veut
dire que certaines certaines formations
qui sont dispensées ne vont plus exister
à la rentrée si elles n'ont pas ass
voilà tout de toute manière pour prouver
approuver ce propos nous avons fermé
temporairement peut-être définitivement
certaines formations à 2014 en master
donc master c'est que des masters qu'on
a qu'on a fermé parce bon il y avait
formation au missier l'enseignement
NOTAM notamment je crois un autre en
chimie voilà mais qui pourront ouvrir
s'il y a des effectifs suffisants donc
là donc il y a un travail qui important
fait sur les MASTER ensuite en terme des
réduction donc on a renégocié un
partenariat public privé donc on a
optimisé nos achats c'estàd on s'est
intégrés dans des groupements d'achat
d'achat d'informatique par exemple ou de
documentation qui vont nous permettre de
faire 300000 € d'économie par an par
ailleurs on a donc com on dit geler des
emplois vous parliez tout à l'heure de
ces parents qui souhaitaient inscrire
leurs enfants en septembre prochain vous
espéz qu'il continue à le faire vous n'z
pas peur que ça freine un petit peu les
les envies de certains devenir sur le
territoire c'est clair je pense que vous
en êtes bien conscient qu'il a eu pas
mal de communication un petit peu je
dirais déléterque qui on pu écorner
l'image deuniversité si je suis là ce
soir c'est justement pour rassurer non
seulement ma communauté mais également
les parents des futurs étudiants pour
dire quel est mon combat par rapport à
la défense de la qualité reconnue de
l'université en terme de réussite
d'insertion une dernière information
pour terminer ce journal on en sait un
peu plus sur l'arrivée d'une grande
société du CAC 40 Mani leamo sur
l'ancien site de nthel dont vous voyez
actuellement les images il s'agirait de
la société safran groupe industriel et
technologique français présent au niveau
international dans les domaines de
l'aéronautique l'astronautique de la
défense et de la sécurité l'installation
officielle doit se faire en cours
d'année pour se terminer en 2015 donc en
lieu et place de la société Nortel on se
quitte pour la dernière fois avec vos
résolutions pour cette nouvelle année et
puis on se retrouve dès lundi pour une
nouvelle semaine d'actualité locale en
weekend j'ai pas de résolution pour 2014
on continue comme avant et puis c'est
tout de voir la vie plus plus au présent
qu'au futur essayeer de vivre chaque
moment comme il doit être
pris des résolutions à faire un peu de
sport voilà passer du doute
philosophique à certaines certitudes
mais comme je je naurais pas de
certitude en utilisant le doute
philosophique je crois que je vais
mainenir au doute philosophieque bonne
résolution c'est trouvé un logement
parce que je suis en train de déménager
2012 cétait arrêté de fumer ça c'est
fait 2013 j'ai arrêté l'apéritif c'est
fait 2014 allez je me mets au sport
allez je vous souhaite à tous une bonne
année